giraffe - Player 01KA8MF8TTSA3RH3QHHVYWG5AE:This
transcript:1
kangaroo - Player 01KA8MF88YNTXEXRSRCS5B9M0R:This
transcript:2
giraffe - Player 01KA8MF8TTSA3RH3QHHVYWG5AE:trend
transcript:3
giraffe - Player 01KA8MF8TTSA3RH3QHHVYWG5AE:chris
transcript:4
kangaroo - Player 01KA8MF88YNTXEXRSRCS5B9M0R:chris
transcript:5
giraffe - Player 01KA8MF8TTSA3RH3QHHVYWG5AE:their
transcript:6
giraffe - Player 01KA8MF8TTSA3RH3QHHVYWG5AE:I
transcript:7
kangaroo - Player 01KA8MF88YNTXEXRSRCS5B9M0R:I am a kangaroo
transcript:8
kangaroo - Player 01KA8MF88YNTXEXRSRCS5B9M0R:You
transcript:9
kangaroo - Player 01KA8MF88YNTXEXRSRCS5B9M0R:new
transcript:10
kangaroo - Player 01KA8MF88YNTXEXRSRCS5B9M0R:and should